thomas tu fais quoi dans la vie moi je
suis en formation d'éducateur spécialisé
d'accord donc vous vient d'orléans
c'était et gilet jaune et tu viens de
voir toutes les semaines on est très
heureux que tu sois là c'est notamment
en fait je voudrais rebondir sur ce qui
est en train de dire thomas et sur
justement une proposition donc là en
fait c'est très bien parce que tu as
déjà mis en fait tout les avantages
qu'ils avaient donc moi ma demande en
fait ça serait justement la suppression
de tous les avantages des anciens
députés ministres et sa renommée mais ça
on l'a déjà fait je vais me reprendre
les retraites
quand vous voyez aucun député un député
qui travaille cinq ans qui touchent
quasiment six mille euros et qui gagne
après les salles comme en forme 1390
euros
j'ai été élu président de l'assemblée
nationale le 27 juin 2009 le 4 août au
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
on a pris la décision de réformer le
système de retraite des députés pour qui
c'est entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier
2010 et donc ça devrait te fasses et les
députés dans leur mandat
eh bien ils auront une pension de
retraite 37 % inférieure à celle d'avant
vous connaissez l'expression kamouni
baisse leur retraite de 37 ans la
retraite après avoir travaillé cinq ans
nous nous en tenons là regardez réputé
c'est à 62 ans si vous aimez moi si je
suis pas si je suis pas en 2022 je suis
parent élu je vais pointer au chômage
ariane allocations chômage et je cherche
du boulot et ma retraite ce sera à 62
ans mais ça c'est normal parce que je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
racontent sur internet ou ailleurs que à
un député il a une retraite d'ex moment
défini qui les 35 40 ou 60 ans je veux
dire à thomas si je peux si je peux me
permettre
et là aussi si le nouveau calcul et le
sac de montréal qué sur le régime est ce
que thomas ce que voulait dire c'est
qu'un député qui travaille cinq ans même
s'il a sa retraite à 62 ans il va avoir
une retraite équivalente voilà à
quelqu'un qui a travaillé toute sa vie
alors qu'il a failli 50 et falcon et en
plus c'est green hills que ça c'est fini
d'accord après il ya tous les avantages
par exemple les obsèques bien c'est fini
aussi font là si vous arrivez diminué
vous avez dit niveau mais non non non
vous avez diminué par rapport à ça on
est passé de 8000 euros à 3000 euros
mais il faut savoir que vous avez le
droit de
par rapport à l'état de payer les
obsèques de votre famille il ya des gens
en france ipone à crédit par rapport
pour pouvoir insérer des dix nations
c'est thomas et là on n'en est pas là il
ya tous ces avantages la cumuler on
reprend les anciens présidents valéry
giscard d'estaing et nous coûte 2
millions 5,2 de valéry giscard d'estaing
ce qui a été président très très jeune
et que millions par an et oui mais vous
savez ma croûte est très chiant c'est
vraiment et même par rapport à tout ça
au niveau justice fiscale et justice par
rapport au peuple
je pense que ça il faut l'abolir il ya
toutes ces tares de la région vous avez
la région qui on n'a pas le droit
vous savez quand j'étais président
l'assemblée nationale il y avait des
avantages pour les anciens présidents de
l'assemblée nationale je les ai supprimé
j'ai dit moi quand je serai ancien
président de l'international mais
j'aurais rien tu dois vous dire que
l'arrivée de supprimer tous les jeux
réforme obama doit toujours rendu très
populaire auprès de tous les députés
mais il ya un moment donné moi j'ai
voulu remettre les choses decker mais ce
que je constate
en réalité c'est que les rumeurs et les
fausses informations elles continuent à
circuler
je continue à voir sur des légendes et
des gens honnêtes on envoie des mails en
dix ans mais il paraît qu'un ancien
député il touche sa paye pendant cinq
ans il est plus député parce que il ya
eu il ya très longtemps un système ça
qui a été réformé les tur hasard mais il
ya du vrai lait les 300 wii ont mis la
main sur trois ans une allocation de
retour à l'emploi pendant trois ans et
dégressif ce lien tous les six mois et
donc au bout de trois ans et zéro
abstention n'a pas varié classe
pourrais-je pas s'en est pas dégressif
on va passer le troisième sujet traité
moi je l'échangé en faisant exactement
comme le système des salariés c'est quoi
à voir aussi fini